[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend in
den slowenischen Katastrophengebieten
scheint sich die Lage etwas zu
stabilisieren zumindest beginnen die
Wasserstände dort zu sinken die größte
Gefahr droht jetzt durch Erdrutsche zwei
Drittel des Landes sind von den
Überschwemmungen betroffen die Schäden
sind gewaltig straßenhäuser Kraftwerke
überall gibt es Zerstörungen
Slowenien hatte die Europäische Union
und die NATO um Hilfe gebeten Christian
von Rechenberg berichtet
der Regen hat aufgehört das Retten nicht
noch immer holen sie wie hier im Norden
Sloweniens die Menschen aus den Trümmern
jene die es aus eigener Kraft nicht mehr
schaffen sich vor denen Sicherheit zu
bringen was als dir wohl größte
Katastrophe Sloweniens in Erinnerung
bleiben wird entlang der großen Flüsse
save 3 oder nur hat das Wasser Straßen
Schienen Ortschaften in seiner Gewalt
und auch von den Hängen droht gefahren
die Erde kommt ins Rutschen an hunderten
stellen nach nur drei Tagen Regen
nein das hat mich nicht überrascht es
waren sehr starke Niederschläge sind
sehr große Mengen in ganz kurzer Zeit in
den Gebieten niedergegangen insofern
sind auch die Böden sehr schnell
übersättigt worden Apokalypse dort wo
die Böden total kamen diese Aufnahmen
irgendwo in Slowenien entstanden lassen
ahnen der Schaden ist gewaltig
mindestens 500 Millionen Euro offiziell
es dürfte deutlich mehr werden aufräumen
so gut es eben geht Slowenien ruft heute
um Hilfe braucht Bagger Brücken und jede
Menge helfen der Hände EU NATO rotes
Kreuz Hilfe ist unterwegs das deutsche
THW schickt ein Vorausteam
wir sind voller Energie und versuchen
uns jetzt das zurückzuholen was uns
genommen wurde wir schaffen das wir sind
Optimisten
trotzdem sechs Tote das ist nicht mehr
wurden verdankt Slowenien seinen Helden
Menschen wie Sandy zeigt der
Feuerwehrmann aus Menger rettete Kinder
aus einem Hort während das Wasser von
Minute zu Minute stieg er fühlte sich
sagt er wie auf der Titanic
die Kinder waren entdecken gehört wir
haben versucht sie zu beruhigen manche
waren vollkommen Stille manche hatten
die Augen weit aufgerissen manche
weinten und riefen nach ihren Eltern
währenddessen verwüstet das Wasser sein
eigenes Zuhause es mag ihm egal sein
Hauptsache die Kinder sind am Leben und
in Sicherheit in Sicherheit sind sie
vorerst auch in St nikolai in der
Steiermark die ganze Nacht haben Helfer
hier hänge gesichert und Schlimmeres
verhindert
wie der Berg geht ohne das was tun der
Süden Österreichs hat es auch noch nicht
überstanden in Kärnten etwa macht die
Glan Probleme das Kanalsystem kommt an
seine Grenzen
auch in Kroatien Pumpen sie an gegen die
Wassermassen gute Nachrichten die Pegel
sinken an vielen Stellen die Dämme und
Deiche halten und den Slowenien fliegen
die Retter weiter so lange es sein muss
und einer dieser Helfer ist Thorsten
Meyer vom Technischen Hilfswerk Detmold
ist jetzt als Einsatzleiter in Slowenien
guten Abend herr Meier
genau sie sind seit heute in dem
Katastrophengebiet konnten sich einen
ersten Eindruck verschaffen wie schätzen
Sie die Lage ein
ja die Bilder die wir heute gesehen
haben sind
vergleichbar mit Bildern die wir auch
aus Deutschland kennen zuletzt
sicherlich immer artal und Teile
der slowenischen Landschaft sehen dem
schon sehr ähnlich also würden sie auch
sagen dass das vom Ausmaß der
Katastrophe vergleichbar ist mit mit der
Flut an die wir uns ja hier in
Deutschland alle sehr erinnern
wir haben auch hier
weggerissene Häuser weggerissene Brücken
und ein großes Maß an Zerstörung in dem
Bereich wo das Hochwasser durchgegangen
ist sind schon viele Bilder vergleichbar
ja was genau ist denn jetzt ihre Aufgabe
bei diesen Einsatz
die slowenische Regierung hat im Rahmen
des europäischen
katastrophenschutzmechanismus um
Unterstützung gebeten benötigt
insbesondere Bagger für rheumarbeiten
benötigt Behelfsbrücken und das TAW kann
beides stellen und wir sind im Moment im
voraussteam hier heute sind auch die
ersten Bagger eingetroffen und wir
werden ab morgen früh dann hier auch mit
praktischer Hilfe unterstützen das heißt
vorausziehen sie schauen quasi wo was am
sinnvollsten eingesetzt wird ganz genau
wir erkunden die Situation mit den
Kollegen aus Slowenien zusammenlegen wir
die Prioritäten fest damit die Hilfe
auch ziegelgerichte zum Einsatz kommt
und es gibt auch einen hohen Bedarf an
ersatzbrücken und das ist von der
Erkundung her ein bisschen aufwendiger
und das haben wir heute schon mal
begonnen
man konnte lesen dass die Slowenien also
auch die NATO z.B um Militärhubschrauber
gebeten haben also es wird offenbar auch
noch sehr viel Geräte gebraucht um
Menschen zu bergen
ja sind Orte noch von Außenwelt
abgeschnitten die müssen versorgt werden
und deswegen werden auch Brücken so
dringend benötigt damit eben die
Zuwegung wieder hergestellt werden
können und die Menschen wieder auf dem
Landwirte erreichbar sind haben sie denn
den Eindruck dass die Organisation
dieser internationalen Hilfe dass das
jetzt gut anläuft dass das auch schnell
gehen wird
also ich habe einen guten Eindruck hier
vor Ort
es geht hier wie ich finde extrem
schnell und gut voran und auch die
internationale Hilfe ist ja durch den
europäischen
katastrophenschutzmechanismus
koordiniert und ich habe einen guten
Eindruck im Moment und aus Deutschland
ist es dann vor allem das THW das im
Einsatz ist ganz genau im Auftrag der
Bundesregierung ist es THW entsandt
worden und ja wir kommen jetzt über die
Tage mit unseren Einheiten ins Land
konnten sie denn überhaupt über die
Straßen so benutzen wie man das dann
eigentlich braucht man da als
voraussteam fährt ich meine wir leben ja
auch dass das jetzt als Transit Land für
Touristen sehr schwierig ist um nach
Kroatien z.B zu kommen oder nach Hause
wie haben sie die Lage vorgefunden die
haben sie sich jetzt dort bewegt ja wir
haben Kollegen das slowenischen
Zivilschutz mit dabei die hier
ortskundig sind und wir müssen um einen
Kilometer weiter zu kommen teilweise
sehr sehr weit fahren aber wir haben bis
jetzt immer noch einen Weg gefunden um
an die Einsatzstellen ranzukommen und
dort zu erkunden also es geht aber es
ist beschwerlich
danke für das Gespräch alles Gute für
ihre Arbeit danke sehr guten Abend
haben wir vor einer Stunde aufgezeichnet
die Ukraine wertet die Friedenskonferenz
am Wochenende in Saudi-Arabien als
Erfolg obwohl es nicht mal eine
gemeinsame Abschlusserklärung gab für
Kiew ist vor allem wichtig mit starken
jenseits der westlichen Allianz ins
Gespräch zu kommen das China
teilgenommen hat ist zumindest
bemerkenswert und auch dass sich alle
Teilnehmer zum Prinzip der territorialen
Unversehrtheit bekannten die Ukraine
will nämlich nicht noch mal ein
sogenannten Frieden akzeptieren bei dem
sie große Teile ihres Landes aufgibt
seit den goldtaten von Butcher ist das
für sie keine Option mehr seit offenbar
wurde was die Russen in den besetzten
Gebieten anrichten wie viele Ukraine
dort verschleppt gefoltert und getötet
werden eine Brühl hatte in der Ukraine
mit einer Frau gesprochen die um ihren
Gefangenen Sohn bankt
Videos am 09.04 22 hat mein Sohn Dima
Geburtstag er wurde 23 Jahre alt ich
gratuliere dir das einzige was wichtig
ist du sollst am leben und gesund sein
es sind Zeilen die Olena uswerk in ihr
Tagebuch notiert hat zu Hause in ihrer
Küche in Hostel
ob die Mitri den alle nur die mal nennen
lebt und gesund ist weiß sie nicht alles
was sie weiß ist dass ihr so nach
Russland verschleppt wurde dort
inhaftiert ist auf dem Handy hat sie ein
Foto von einer russischen Website es ist
mehr als vier Monate alt
es war gut zu sehen dass er damals am
Leben war ich hoffe dass es doch heute
noch so den momentan gibt es keine
Information von ihm ihre Arbeit sagt sie
gebe ihr halt sie ist ärztliche
Direktorin von vier Polikliniken der
Gemeinde hostdommel und sie kämpft für
ihren Sohn der britische Außenminister
hat ihre Geschichte vor die
Vollversammlung der Vereinten Nationen
getragen
und ihr 22 Jahre alter Sohn die Mitri
wurden von russischen Truppen aus ihrem
Haus in hospital in der Nähe von Butcher
entführt im März
von russischer Seite keine Reaktion
in Hoster Mel zeigt Olena uns das Haus
in dem ihre Familie verhört und
gefoltert wurde
nach dem Verhör hat man uns Plastiktüten
über den Kopf gestirbt und danach haben
sie uns den Hals mit Klebeband umwickelt
sie haben versucht uns ersticken zu
lassen wir waren eine Zeit lang ohne
Sauerstoff und mein Sohn saß neben mir
und hat gesagt Mama ich kann nicht mehr
atmen
das sind die letzten Worte die sie von
Dima hört ihr Mann kommt Wochen später
frei ihr Sohn aber bleibt verschwunden
er ist einer von 25.000 ukrainischen
Zivilisten die die Russen verschleppt
haben die Zahl hat der ukrainische
Menschenrechtsbeauftragte gerade genannt
kann man das was du und deine Familie
erlebt haben überhaupt bewältigen
das schlimme ist sehr
erstens ist es für mich keine
Vergangenheit das ist mein heutiges
Leben denn meine Wunde ist offen und sie
bleibt offen bis mein Sohn zu Hause ist
für mich ist die Zeit stehen geblieben
die Hoffnung auf ein Wiedersehen nicht
auf auf dem Küchentisch steht immer ein
Teller für Dima
bei Gefangenen genommenen Soldaten
können die Angehörigen auf einen
Gefangenenaustausch hoffen auch heute
kamen auf diesem Weg wieder 22
ukrainische Soldaten frei für Zivilisten
gibt es ein solches Format jedoch nicht
mehr hintergrundde und aktuelle
Informationen zum Kriegsgeschehen finden
Sie online auf ZDF heute mit der Ukraine
geht es jetzt auch bei dir erst noch mal
weiter Hans die russische Armee hat dort
erneut Städte bombardiert am Abend
meldete die Ukraine das in progrowski im
Osten russische Raketen ein Wohngebäude
getroffen haben fünf Menschen sein
getötet und mindestens 31 verletzt
worden auch in der Region Harris sollen
zuvor zwei Menschen getötet worden sein
und die Stadt herson im Süden stand
offenbar stundenlang unter Beschuss auch
hier wurde ein Wohnhaus getroffen nach
ukrainischen Angaben kam eine Bewohnerin
ums Leben mehrere Menschen wurden
verletzt
deutsche Unternehmen haben künftig
weitere Möglichkeiten ihre Geschäfte in
der Ukraine abzusichern die
Bundesregierung Weite die
Investitionsgarantien aus neben
eigentumsschäden werden auch bestimmte
Kreditrisiken abgesichert durch enge
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen sollte die
Voraussetzung geschaffen werden
möglichst früh am Wiederaufbau zu
arbeiten
nach dem Militärputsch bleibt die Lage
im Niger angespannt die westafrikanische
Staatengemeinschaft ecovas kündigte an
am Donnerstag auf einem sonntaggipfel
über die Situation zu beraten ein
Ultimatum der ecovas war zuvor
abgelaufen in dem das wieder einsetzen
des Präsidenten gefordert und mit einem
militärischen einschreiten gedroht
worden war ein Sprecher der selbst
ernannten Regierung im Niger warnte
gestern Abend die Nachbarstaaten jeder
versucht den nigerianischen Luftraum zu
verletzen werde eine energische und
sofortige Gegenreaktion nach sich ziehen
Entschuldigung ist nicht der
nigerianische Luftraum sondern der
niederschluftraum
in Großbritannien hat die konservative
Regierung mit der Unterbringung von
Asylsuchenden auf einem umgebauten
Lastkahn begonnen sie wolle damit das
Platzproblem bei der Unterbringung von
Migranten lösen dass sie mehrere
Millionen Pfund am Tag Kosten auf dem
Kahn Baby Stockholm trafen am Montag die
ersten ein insgesamt sollen hier 500
Männer auf den Ausgang ihres
Asylverfahrens warten
Menschenrechtsorganisationen warnen vor
einer Retraumatisierung von Flüchtlingen
Botschafter in Paris zu sein ist ein
Diplomaten Traumjob Washington London
Paris Brüssel das sind traditionell sehr
begehrte Posten in der Regel ist man auf
einer solchen Station nur einmal für
einige Jahre bis man dann nach dem
Rotationsprinzip wieder nach Berlin
zurückkehrt oder in eine andere Stadt
weiterzieht der neue deutsche
Botschafter in Paris Stefan Steinlein
tritt diesen Job aber nun schon zum
zweiten Mal an und für zwei verschiedene
Staaten wie das Andreas Kühnast erzählt
die Hintergründe dieses
deutsch-deutschen Lebenslaufs
das ist der zweite erste Tag von Stefan
Steinlein als Botschafter in Frankreich
an seinem ersten Tag gab es Ehefrau
Francois noch nicht und das vereinigte
Deutschland noch nicht und diese
Sicherheitsschleusen Türen noch nicht
die dem neuen Botschafter der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland an diesem
Morgen nicht übermäßig feierlich
geöffnet werden an seinem ersten Tag war
Steinlein keine 30 kein Diplomat und
keiner der in der nachwände DDR auf
Karriere gehofft hat es war
wahrscheinlich nach heutigen Maßstäben
ziemlich verrückt aber damals eigentlich
ganz normal sehr viele Leute gerade auch
in Osteuropa waren etwa in meinem Alter
und mussten plötzlich Verantwortung
übernehmen weil die älteren
diskreditiert waren und man einfach neue
Gesichter brauchte unbelastete Menschen
brauchte von heute auf morgen muss DDR
Außenminister Markus Meckel der selbst
gerade noch Pfarrer war dutzende Posten
besetzen um ein Jahrhundertwerk
auszuhandeln die deutsche Einheit
ich suche den krampfhaft nach Menschen
die ein wenig außen Erfahrung hatten die
Sprache sprachen und vertrauenswürdig
waren und so wurde Stefan dann
Botschafter der DDR in Frankreich
Stephan Steinlein ist 29 Theologe und
kommt in ein wie Markus Meckel es nennt
feindliches Haus im Ministerium für
auswärtige Angelegenheiten arbeiten
neben den professionellsten auch die
dogmatischsten sed-diplomaten in der
Botschaft in der Steinlein Stefan Chef
wird im kapitalistischen Frankreich erst
recht auch das war für beide Seiten
glaube ich eine merkwürdige Erfahrung
wir werden uns in der DDR wahrscheinlich
nie gegeben hat die einen haben sich
dann wirklich als loyal erwiesen und
haben versucht unsere Orientierung ja zu
fundamentieren und mit Argumenten zu
versehen sie haben alle sich die Frage
gestellt was wird aus Ihnen und hat
natürlich auch Angst dass sie in die
Arbeitslosigkeit gehen müssten andere
warne Distanz und man merkte deutlich
dass sie etwas anderes wollten nach der
Wiedervereinigung fängt Steinlein von
vorn an diplomatenausbildung
Pressestelle Referent dann wird der
letzte ddr-botschafter in Paris die
rechte Hand von Frank-Walter Steinmeier
dem er durch all seine Funktionen folgt
den Versuch einer einbindenden
russland-politik findet Steinlein
richtig sagt aber auch er sei
gescheitert das Frankreich Bild des
ersten Botschafters Steinlein war noch
geprägt durch die in der DDR enorm
populären Filme von Louis de Finesse
aber ich habe mittlerweile Frankreich
natürlich ganz anders kennengelernt ich
habe eine französische Frau ich habe
Kinder die in Paris studiert haben so
dass ich eigentlich doch Paris und
Frankreich mittlerweile sehr viel besser
erkennen als durch diese Filme was
Steinlein sich wünscht an seinem zweiten
ersten Tag das ist diesmal länger dauert
als sechs Wochen
eher schlechte Nachrichten gibt es heute
von der deutschen Wirtschaft die
Industrieproduktion ist im Juli mit
einem Minus von 1,5% stärker
zurückgegangen als erwartet Deutschland
steckt also weiter in einer
Konjunkturflaute aktuelle ursachen dafür
gibt es viele hohe Energiepreise hohe
Zinsen und auch die Weltwirtschaft war
längere Zeit eher mau nun wird
diskutieren wie die Bundesregierung
gegensteuern kann CDU CSU fordern ein
Konjunkturprogramm die ampelparteien
halten das für weniger sinnvoll und
weisen auf langfristig wirkende
strukturelle Ursachen hin die Grünen
sprechen zum Beispiel über
Digitalisierung die FDP über Bürokratie
abbauen das Bürokratie
Wirtschaftswachstum hemmen kann wird von
Unternehmen ja schon seit langem beklagt
Oliver Heuchert beginnt sein Bericht mit
einem dafür typischen Beispiel
Papier gewordene Aufwand einer
Heizungsanlage auszutauschen Bauanträge
Förderanträge gewässerrechtliche
Genehmigungen neue Vorschriften über die
Höhe des Kamins
beim Unternehmen wie haarwerkzeuge im
Schwarzwald haben sie mehr als 1,5
Millionen Euro in diese
pelletheizungsanlage gesteckt auch um
CO2 einzusparen die Auszahlung des
grundsätzlich zugesagten Fördergeld über
insgesamt 500.000 Euro zieht sich in
Etappen hin die zuständige Behörde
fordert immer wieder zusätzliche
Nachweise ist aber selbst schlecht
erreichbar Unternehmer Hahn ist entnervt
in der Regel kommt dann per Post eine
Auflistung was noch alles fehlt oder was
was an Rückfragen da ist ja und dann
nehmen sich versucht man sich die ganzen
Informationen wieder zu beschaffen was
man jetzt alles braucht
das kann einem häufig keiner sagen dann
muss man sich in Gesetzestexte wieder
einlesen stellt manchmal fest dass die
Sachen die gefordert werden gar nicht
für einen zutreffen Rückfragen stellen
ist aber nicht und nach bestem Wissen
und Gewissen lädt man dann die nächste
Runde hoch hört lange nichts und ein
paar Wochen später kommt dann gleich
wieder mit verzugsandrohung die nächste
Aufforderung was man noch alles
nachzuliefern hat Wilhelm Hahn schildert
viele solche bürokratievorfälle ein
Seele oder das lange nicht gebaut werden
kann weil immer neue
Brandschutzmaßnahmen gefordert werden
ein Grundstück das jahrelang nicht
gekauft werden kann weil die betroffenen
Gemeinden sich nicht einigen
das Familienunternehmen Wiha stellt vor
allem handwerkerwerkzeuge her und 150
Millionen Euro Umsatz im Jahr etwa 1.500
Beschäftigte produziert und verkauft
wird weltweit seit wieher solche
Akkuschrauber produziert und in Europa
vertreibt muss das Unternehmen für alle
EU-Staaten einzeln die
Entsorgungsnachweise der Batterien
vorlegen allein sprachlich aber auch
juristisch ein enormer Aufwand
wie Herr fühlt sich wie die meisten
Unternehmen in Deutschland von der
Bürokratie überfordert von der schieren
Menge an Vorschriften von der schlechten
Kommunikation mit den wenig
digitalisierten Behörden und ihre
Entscheidungsschwäche von der Dauer und
der Umständlichkeit der Verfahren das
liegt auch an der Dominanz der Juristen
in der Bürokratie viele
Verwaltungsmitarbeiter orientieren sich
aufgrund ihrer juristischen Ausbildung
nicht besonders gut an Problemlösung
sondern ein Rechtssicherheit sie möchten
keinen Fehler machen sie haben Angst
davor das eventuell der Rechnungshof
kommt oder ihr Vorgesetzte sich
beschwert und dann wenn Sie diese
komplizierten Verfahren die wir haben
bis zuletzt an und sind nicht flexibel
genug um auch für Unternehmen aber auch
für Bürger Lösungen zu schaffen
beim Werkzeughersteller viha bremst die
Bürokratie die Investitionen in
Deutschland auf unser konkretes
Investitionsverhalten der letzten Jahre
hatte das die Auswirkung dass
lagererweiterungen wurden in den USA
gemacht
produktionsarbeiterungen wurden in
Vietnam oder Polen gemacht in
Deutschland machen wir eine
Substanzerhaltung wir machen es
Sanierung wir machen auch vor allem
energetische Sanierung aber groß an
Erweiterungen
wird nach Möglichkeit nicht hier gemacht
sondern leider tatsächlich im Ausland
weniger Investitionen im Inland wegen
der Bürokratie das ist keine gute
Entwicklung des Standorts Deutschland
und mit Wirtschaft geht es bei dir jetzt
auch noch weiter Heinz und das
Wirtschafts- und klimaschutzminister
Habeck will Investitionen in eine
klimaneutrale Wirtschaft beschleunigen
von der EU gibt es einen neuen Rahmen
für Beihilfen und auf dieser Grundlage
sollen Bund und Länder jetzt spezifische
Förderprogramme erlassen können zur
Produktion von ausgewählten
transformationstechnologien wie
Windkraft und Photovoltaikanlagen oder
Batterien und damit weiter zur Börse bei
der realer es gibt neues von Siemens
Energy ja keine guten Nachrichten mal
wieder muss man sagen Siemens Energy hat
ein milliardenschweres minus eingefahren
Schuld daran ausgerechnet das Geschäft
mit dem Zukunftsthema Windenergie die
Tochter Siemens Gamesa ist ein
dauersorgen Kind das ist da Probleme gab
war bekannt nun aber sprengen sie noch
mal den Rahmen größer kostenpunkt
gravierende Qualitätsmängel bei
Windturbinen an Land ein Schaden der
aufwendig behoben werden
aber auch das Offshore-Geschäft kommt
nicht wie gewünscht den Gang vor allem
das Hochfahren seiner Produktion macht
im abgelaufenen Quartal einen
Rekordverlust von fast 3 Milliarden Euro
viereinhalb Milliarden könnten daraus am
Ende des Jahres werden das Urteil der
Börse eindeutig Anleger sind geschockt
die Papiere über 6% im Minus der Rest
von Siemens Energy das klassische
traditionelle Stromgeschäft mit fossilen
Energieträgern verdient gerade das Geld
die Windkraft jedoch ist seit Jahren ein
Problemfall wann in der Schwarte
schwarze Zahlen zu erwarten sind dafür
gab es bislang keine Vorhersage für
Siemens Gamesa soll es eine neue
Strategie geben aber erst im November
vielen Dank
die Deutsche Post darf das Briefporto
nicht vorzeitig erhöhen einen
entsprechenden Antrag hat die
Bundesnetzagentur abgelehnt die Post
wollte die Preise bereits im kommenden
Jahr anheben und begründete den Antrag
unter anderem mit gestiegenen Kosten
der frühere Keyboard oder und Mitgründer
der Band Karat Ulrich it's Wilms ist
gestorben nach Angaben des Managements
der Band starb der Musiker bereits am 27
juni im Alter von 76 Jahren für die in
der ehemaligen DDR gegründete Band Karat
komponierte swims zahlreiche Lieder
darunter auch den Hit über sieben
Brücken musst du gehen
[Musik]
zu gehen
der später von Peter Maffay gecovert
wurde
zur Fußball-WM da wird im Gastgeber Land
Australien gefeiert denn das Team ist in
der WM Endrunde weiter dabei durch einen
2:0 Sieg heute gegen Dänemark mit
Heimvorteil in Sydney gingen die
Australierinnen in der 29 minute in
Führung und in der 70 minute dann der
zweite Treffer
partystimmungen in Australien das also
im Viertelfinale steht
[Applaus]
und dort entweder auf Frankreich oder
auf Marokko trifft der letzte
achtelfinalspieltag morgen im ZDF von
9:45 Uhr an und alle Tore alle
Höhepunkte der WM gibt es bei uns auch
gebündelt online oder ZDF heute.de aber
hier noch der kurze Blick auf das andere
Achtelfinale von heute in dem in
Brisbane die Europameisterinnen aus
England erst im Elfmeterschießen gegen
die Mannschaft aus Nigeria gewonnen
haben nach der Verlängerung hatte es 0:0
gestanden nach dem Elfmeterschießen dann
4:2 für England
es gab Dampfnudeln Kartoffelknödel
Schweinskopf Grießnockerl Sauerkraut
Leberkäse Kaiserschmarrn und Gugelhupf
natürlich der darf nicht fehlen wenn nun
an einen bayerisches Wirtshaus denkt
liegt im Prinzip nicht ganz falsch hat
aber offenbar eine ganze Erfolgsserie im
Buch und Film verpasst die Krimireihe um
den Dorf Polizisten Franz Eberhofer
kommt diese Woche mit einer neuen Folge
in die Kinos diesmal gibt es einen
rendez Rehragout Brigitte Saar hat es
schon mal getestet
das Drama beginnt na klar mit einem
Rehragout und einem Befreiungsschlag die
Oma will weg was Franz Eberhofer und den
Rest der Familie hart trifft
Zustand ein Status Quo erstellen der
dann auch so zu bleiben hat also die Oma
bleibt die Oma und muss kochen und Ding
und zwar gar nicht weil er sie ausnutzen
will sondern weil er das als Konstrukt
kennt und sich darin wohlfühlt wieder
gibt es einen Mord in
Niederkaltenkirchen Franz ermittelt doch
das passt seiner Susi so gar nicht denn
als frischgebackene Bürgermeister
Stellvertreterin will sie das Dorf ganz
groß rausbringen
ich versuche gerade den unique sailing
point von Niederkaltenkirchen zu finden
und du veranstaltest du ein riesen
brennbarium wegen einem einzigen Uhr es
ist der 9 Eberhofer Film die
Fan-Gemeinde ist riesig die Geschichten
sind immer ein bisschen
hinterwäldlerisch voller SATA Klischees
und treffen auch außerhalb Bayerns einen
Nerv provinzkomödien sind weil das Thema
Provinz erzählt wird der Mikrokosmos
Kaff wo sich jeder kennt und was auch so
zurück ist und wo auf einmal viel mehr
Individuen zu erkennen sind
einfach am Arsch immer wieder kocht die
bayerische Seele über und explodiert mit
einer Wortgewalt die beeindruckt auch
wenn man nicht jede einzelne Silbe
versteht
du von mir ich habe wirklich einen Hund
auf bayerisch schimpfen das ist ein
Kulturgut das gehört dazu das darf man
auch dann also der granteln der
Taxifahrer oder wenn man ins Wirtshaus
geht der wird der einen angewandeltes
das gehört irgendwie dazu der Bayer ist
der immer auf die 12 aber es trotzdem
von einer großen Herzlichkeit geprägt
auf dem roten Teppich bei der Premiere
in München sind die Hauptdarsteller
alles andere als derbund provinziell
unterwegs darunter auch Simon schwarz
der hatte es als Privatdetektiv Rudi bei
den Dreharbeiten nicht leicht
[Musik]
nur zur Beruhigung beim Absenken in die
Güllegrube ist er nicht im Kuhmist
gelandet sondern in einem Mix aus
Heilerde Torf und Fango
gut aber das auch noch geklärt mit Kino
geht's dann hier gleich auch weiter mit
dem ZDF montagskino und um 23:50 Uhr
meldet sich dann Laura barnick mit
unserem britischen Update morgen wieder
bis dahin
[Musik]
guten Abend es ist noch immer sehr
windig draußen und auch heute abend
drohen noch schwere Sturmböen an den
Küsten mit Windgeschwindigkeiten von 100
Kilometern pro Stunde an der Küste
bleibt die Nacht recht Bild bei 15 bis
13 Grad sonst wird sie frisch mit 12 bis
6 Grad und dann kältesten wird es am
Alpenrand zum Teil ist der Himmel auch
klar hier zum Beispiel Baden-Württemberg
in Rheinland-Pfalz und dem Saarland der
Regen lässt erstmal nach aber morgen
kommt schon gleich das nächste Tief hier
von Großbritannien hinterher und das
bedeutet für die Mitte und den Norden
Deutschlands neuer Regen das Sturmtief
Zacharias wird dann morgen bereits
Norwegen erreichen und dort sehr viel
Regen mitbringen bei uns also morgen
schon in den Vormittag Stunden wieder
kräftiger Regen in Norddeutschland zum
Teil ist der mit Gewittern durchsetzt
der Wind lässt etwas nach etwas
Freundliches ist hier im südlichen
Brandenburg und in Sachsen-Anhalt und
bis zum Mittag haben die Regenfälle dann
noch die Mittelgebirge erreicht in
Süddeutschland bleibt der Dienstag aber
freundlich Sonne und Wolken wechseln
sich miteinander ab die
Höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 17 Grad in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und in Schleswig-Holstein
und 24 Grad am Oberrhein und damit
passen diese Temperaturen ganz gut zu
Mitteleuropa ja selbst in Reykjavik gibt
es morgen Höchsttemperaturen von 15 Grad
die Hitze die verbirgt sich hier über
die iberischen Halbinsel dort sind das
morgen 45 Grad und diese Wärme macht
sich auf den Weg zu uns bis zum
Wochenende das bedeutet dann vielleicht
sogar schon am Freitag Temperaturen von
29 Grad guten Abend